Now to South Asia, and the Taliban government of Afghanistan...
…has ordered an indefinite ban on university education for women.
The order was signed by the Minister of Higher Education,...
…further restricting women's access to formal schooling.
Just three months after thousands of girls and women...
...sat university entrance exams across the country.
Azade Mashiri has this report.
The Taliban takeover meant only one thing for the women and girls of Afghanistan:...
...fear.
Fear they'd lose their freedoms, their education, their future.
More than a year later, the direction of travel has been cemented.
Women no longer have access to university.
Women of Afghanistan have been doomed from the very first day...
...that this group took over.
Like the flagship of conduct is oppression of women.
The war in Afghanistan has not ended.
There is no peace.
There has been a steady stream of setbacks.
Here are just a few.
In March, the Taliban broke their promise to reopen secondary school for girls.
Two months later, women were forced to veil their faces, as well as their hair.
In September, the Women's Affairs Ministry was disbanded...
...and only last month,...
...women were barred from parks, gyms, and swimming pools in the capital.
It's another very troubling, troubling move...
...and it's difficult to imagine how a country can develop,...
...can deal with all of its, the challenges that it has...
...without the active participation of women and the education of women.